With Jupiter Ascending out now, let’s take
a look at 11 / 12 things you probably didn’t
know about the Wachowskis’ sci-fi adventure!
Caine Wise may zip and zoom about on a pair
of air-surfing boots, but in reality, actor
Channing Tatum used a pair of skates on a
system of ramps, platforms and cables to give
the feeling of airborne movement.
With the help of 6 men pulling wires behind
a green screen, Tatum rollerbladed at 4 and
a half miles per hour on a giant three-sided
treadmill four metres long and two metres
wide.
The wheels of the skates, of course, were
erased during post-production!
Pro inline skater Cory Miller from California,
and vert skater Taïg Khris from France helped
train Channing Tatum and the Jupiter Ascending
stunt team.
Tatum had no previous rollerblading experience,
and in the beginning found it tough to skate
fast and still stop in time to throw or block
a punch.
But according to the actor, he started to
get the hang of it when he just kept his skates
on all day!
Taïg Khris is best known for his 2010 drop
from the Eiffel Tower onto a vert ramp which
broke the world record for the highest inline
skate jump.
But he also performed Caine Wise’s leap
from the second floor balcony of the Great
Hall in the Natural History Museum, which
doubled for Kalique’s palace.
And he “flew” through Ely Cathedral, which
doubled as the chapel on Titus’ ship.
Caine Wise is a genetically-engineered human
whose DNA was spliced with that of a wolf.
Director Lana Wachowski discovered that real
wolves hunt in packs and that wolves exiled
from the pack, as Caine was in Jupiter Ascending,
almost always die unless they become a super-hunter.
Caine’s splice of wolf DNA enhances his
skills and heightens his senses.
Over 1.3 million Swarovski crystals were used
on the film’s costumes.
Jupiter’s white and ruby gown, for example,
features hundreds of crystals as well as hand-made
flowers, and a headdress of ruby flowers and
more crystals.
Also, 3D printing was used to create both
Jupiter’s headdress and some of the jewellery
seen in the movie.
The movie’s first big action sequence, which
begins at Chicago’s Willis Tower and darts
under bridges and above the city’s skyline,
is a blend of physical stunts by the actors
and stunt doubles, practical location shots,
visual effects, and green-screen stage work.
It took an amazing 8 months of planning to
carry out the aerial work in that scene.
First, the Jupiter Ascending crew perfected
the stunt choreography in the safe environment
of Warner Bros. Studios in Leavesden in the
UK.
After that, they did test runs in Long Beach,
California, to confirm that performers suspended
from helicopters could carry out a series
of flying poses, while being filmed by cameras
positioned on other helicopters.
Once filming proper began, parts of downtown
Chicago were closed and completely evacuated
in the early morning and nightfall for two
weeks.
This was so that low-level helicopters with
Channing Tatum and Mila Kunis’s stunt doubles
suspended from them could fly around buildings,
while a second helicopter filmed the action.
At the same time, a third helicopter filmed
background plates for the hundreds of visual
effects shots of downtown Chicago’s destruction.
On top of this, there were 4 camera crews
on rooftops along the route to capture additional
footage.
Because big-action chase scenes are so complicated,
they’re typically shot in daylight or at
night to give filmmakers as much time as possible
to get all the shots they need.
However, the Wachowskis wanted to film just
before sunrise to capture the unique look
and feel of that time of day.
That meant their shoot had a very tight schedule;
just 30 minutes from 5.15am to 5.45am, to
be precise!
To capture the best action shots on location,
the movie’s visual effects supervisor Dan
Glass and cinematographer John Toll created
a new 6-camera rig named the Panocam, which
was fixed to a helicopter.
This new rig captured super-wide angle views
at very high resolutions for many shots, which
they later painted their computer-generated
images on to.
CG creature Greeghan, who’s one of Balem’s
deadly royal guards, is a sort of 7-foot tall
lizard with a 20-foot wingspan and a whip-like
tail.
To prepare for his motion-capture performance,
actor Ariyon Bakare, who portrays Greeghan,
studied the movements of lizards such as Komodo
dragons, and aimed to combine human intelligence
with a reptile’s agility and unpredictability.
The design of the spaceships in Jupiter Ascending
was influenced by the history of transportation
and the fact that rich people have always
travelled in style.
The Wachowskis wanted to reflect this by giving
their spaceships a sense of opulence they
thought was generally missing in sci-fi movies.
The film’s various spacecraft are sleek
and agile, with designs inspired by nature,
for example, insects or birds of prey.
Production Designer Hugh Bateup adapted the
hallways and display areas at London’s Natural
History Museum to create the set of Kalique’s
palace.
Later, gilded domes and spires were added
digitally.
The chapel scene on Titus’s ship was filmed
at Ely Cathedral in Cambridgeshire, England.
Production designer Hugh Bateup combined the
Cathedral’s sandstone gothic features with
modern steel-framed window structures and
light fixtures created by set decorator Peter
Walpole and the prop department.
As for the overall look of Titus’s home,
that was influenced by a variety of styles
including Gothic and Art Deco architecture,
as well as the huge pillars of old English
churches, and the wood finishes and brass
or gold trim of mid-19th-century luxury yachts.
Balem’s home is a vast space which includes
a lab and refinery, and brings to mind both
a steel mill and a supercollider.
To create that world, the crew constructed
enormous sets at Leavesden Studios and the
visual effects team surrounded those sets
with floor-to-ceiling green screens.
Balem’s world is a spin on gothic and industrial
styles, with added opulence.
Well there you have it, 12 things you probably
didn't know about Jupiter Ascending!
Now, tell me, what’s your favourite sci-fi
movie?
If you enjoyed this video, hit the thumbs-up
button and subscribe for more things you didn't
know and weekly movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching! Yippee-ki-yay, movie
lovers!